on va tester votre capacité à draguer à
séduire ce soir parce que je suis très
va faire entrer
tu vas rentrer dans le personnage de
marc des personnes vont venir sur le
plateau une par une
il faudra que tu les draps qui aura
trente secondes à chaque fois pour
séduire les personnes
on va démarrer avec la première
prétendante c'est calme
[Applaudissements]
trop belle bonjour mais magnifique c'est
camille c'était nécessaire de cannes où
je ne restais cimes du maroc pour y
rester là restées là pour cause de
collines l'intention y est ça qui compte
alors qu'amy a joué dans le cas mais in
paris sur netflix
oui j'avais que ça en boutique mois ses
marques marques
oui je suis pilote d'avion pilote de
ligne j'avais envie d'aller au septième
ciel vous de l'argent sur un compte
alors payez vous habiller oui et
rejoignez moi
[Rires]
le pecs a priori c'est à dire que quand
même il ya quelque chose on va en
voiture la deuxième prétendante
je manquais c'est quoi ton type de femme
dans la vraie vie oui j'ai zéro type de
femme d'accord et ben écoute ça tombe
bien je suis à 360 degrés marc garde on
accueille with
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le petit jeune
bonjour alors est ce qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'une canne 2 mais une troisième
essai pour le fun parce qu'elle gère
ouais c'est vrai j'aime les fleurs
j'aime les femmes d'expérience ça tombe
bien c'est comme les vieux livres et ça
se lit bien tu t'adresse un gars le plus
nul en drag de la plaine j'adore mais
c'est très rapide sont avait été séduit
mais oui parce que j'aime sans rire bas
très bien j'aime bien comme ça c'est
merci
allez on termine avec
apparemment il a mangé mokhtar
ça m'arrange vous êtes très beau et très
beau merci c'est gentil il à chaud à
angers rougir vous êtes très joli très
jolie ya quoi dans tes biceps de l'amour
qu'on tient là le s'est confié à la cua
daliot à l'hélium
ouais ben si tu m'en donnait un petit
peu j'adore rire bonjour et du vénitien
pas louis devoyon madore de 2,2 donc
tellement ça c'est beaucoup c'est un
revenu de 3 2 en une heure et demie non
non-stop l'heure elle est remplie de
hazard va très bien merci
[Applaudissements]